(electronic music)
- Aw fuck!
(laughing)
Is that everybody else's
reaction to Mediterranean?
- Mediterranean
- Okay. M
- E
- D-I-T
- All right now this is
where it gets tricky.
- E-R-R
- E
- A
- I
- N-E-A-N, Mediterranean
(bell sound)
Yeah!
(buzzer sound)
- Dammit!
(bell sound)
- Yeah!
- Woo! Fire.
(bell sound)
- Of course it is!
(buzzer sound)
- Are you sure?
- Privilege
- P-R
- G-E
- Privilege (buzzer sound)
Fuck!
(buzzer sound)
- Dammit!
(bell sound)
- Yes!
(buzzer sound)
- Aww, what did I do?
- What?
(buzzer sound)
- Yeah.
(bell sound)
- Killin' it.
- Definitely? Oh I definitely
know how to spell this.
- Definitely know how to spell definitely.
- Now this one, I definitely know.
- D
- E
- F
- Just "def", no. (laughs)
- I
- N
- E
- I-T
- E-L-Y, definitely.
(bell sound)
- Yes!
- Yeah.
(bell sound)
- Yay.
- Yes!
(buzzer sound)
- Yeah.
- Woo!
- Diarrhea, cha cha cha.
D
- I
- A
- H
- R-R
- H-E
- A-H
(bell sound)
- Yes! Woo!
- All right.
(bell sound)
- Yes.
(buzzer sound)
- Yep.
- I don't know what diarrhea is.
I've never had it in my life.
- Embarrassment
E-M
- B
- A
- R-R
- E
- A
- S-M
- S
- M
- E
- N-T
Embarrassment
(buzzer sound)
Yep.
- Dammit!
(buzzer sound)
- Aww, that makes no sense.
(bell sound)
- All right.
- Yes!
(buzzer sound)
- Goddammit.
- Misspell
- M
- I
- S-P
- S
- P
- E
- L-L
- Misspell.
(buzzer sound)
(bell sound)
- They call me Spell Check.
(buzzer)
- That's stupid.
The English language is dumb.
(bell sound)
(sighs)
- I was a spelling bee
champion in elementary school.
(buzzer sound)
- I knew I was a bad
speller going into it,
so I'm not surprised.
But why do I need to be a good speller
when I have auto correct?
It's gonna change it anyways.
- You know, that's what
dictionaries are for.
- The English language is dumb.